now looking at china and the question of
are its rigid coronavirus policies
endangering global trade overseas
businesses say that beijing's hardline
zero coved strategy could ultimately
lead to empty shells in stores all over
the world we got a taste of the possible
impact in august when a single doc
worker got infected with the coronavirus
in ningbo the government reacted by
closing an entire terminal in the
world's second largest port holding up
50 container ships and effecting global
sea freight now china's current uptick
in cases could prove even worse right
now there are four port cities that are
under threat of lockdown they're still
running but there have already been
delays to logistics centers because of
tightened measures experts at the
peterson institute for international
economics for example say that china
could actually end up broadening its
measures if it's proven that it's
sino-farm vaccines are not as
sufficiently effective against the
omicron variant as they need them to be
so i've been speaking to our
correspondent in taipei tsung han so i
asked him what toll china's tough
pandemic approach was already having on
its own economy
well china's zero tolerance approach
could lead to disappointing consumption
growth this year more serious economic
damage more widespread state
intervention and more disgruntled crowds
weak domestic demand remains a major
problem for china at the moment
according to official statistics china's
annual growth rate for consumption and
investment both fell to single digits
late last year from 10 digit growth in
early 2021 due to the epidemic control
in many parts of china at the same time
china has faced economic headwinds
including the shrinking population a
property sector slowdown and local
government debt it's a big challenge for
the authorities to boost market
confidence while maintaining the zero
covet
strategy we've been hearing about the
concern there is outside of china about
what impact its measures could have on
global trade exactly what sort of effect
could it have
well china's economy has been the main
local motive of global growth in the
last few years and china is likely to
remain the world's leading exporter for
the near future with strong external
demand for things like consumer
electronics furniture and other home
comforts but now millions of small and
family-owned private
businesses have crumbled during the
pandemic we could expect renewed
disruption of supply chains and the
slowing chinese economy would certainly
be a new hit to the global recovery and
if the slowdown were to be serious
enough some experts worry that it could
even potentially plunge the global
economy into a new recession so it's
definitely a concern yeah and this is
all about obviously how china interacts
with the rest of the world we've heard
from president xi jinping this week he
addressed the world economic forum's
virtual davos event what message did we
get from him about how he sees china
engaging with the rest of the world
if we compare um the speech with his
words from a year ago at the same event
we can find a big contrast he was then
talking about global governance a very
high profile gesture to the usa and the
implication that the rise in the east
and the full in the west but this year
the speech has been toned down to talk
about his opposition to the new cold war
and his hope to maintain the smooth and
stable global industrial supply chain
and to reframe from high barriers that
divide trade investment and technology
he also promised
reform and opening up to retain foreign
investment so we can see xi jinping's
shift to a lower profile this year
okay sometimes so in taipei forest thank
you very much